sabemos que viene en dinero de los eeuu
que sabemos que vienen mucha influencia
en las redes sociales en los estados
unidos que han pronunciado mucho a lo
que está sucediendo en los estado en
canadá sabemos que había discurso de
itrón del apoyo sabemos que había mucho
discurso en fox news de usted eeuu en
apoyos no decir que todos esos bienes de
los eeuu en sí por supuesto hay grupos
en canadá que son afines de belleza
mentalidad y manera de pensar pero lo
que empezó como una protesta se suponen
controles de restricciones ya va mucho
más allá y cada día más parece más de la
ultraderecha de los eeuu por ejemplo es
absurdo ver por en en notaba la bandera
de los rebeldes de los eeuu de manguera
este bien hace 200 años y ese es un 100
150 o más por hay 160 años de este es
absurdo la bandera de los nazis o sea
hay mucha cosa que hay que tener esas
protestas en común que hemos visto en la
autora derecha de los eeuu pero todavía
del gobierno y otros están investigando
los enlaces y la influencia de
que viene de fuera de canadá